perfide sex falle einer erst 18-jährigen
die schülerin sarah aus franken tötet
ihre 39-jährige internet-bekanntschaft
eiskalt beim ersten treffen aus purer
lust am morden jetzt ist gegen die
killer schülerin ein hotel gefahren
ich hätte nie gedacht dass es so etwas
jemals geben kann eine erst 18 jährige
schülerin aus franken wird zum mörderin
weil sie fan eines amerikanischen
serienkiller ist noch mal kurz
hervorgehoben sarah ist gerade mal 18
als sie ihre internet bekanntschaft sei
in eine tödliche falle lockt sie tötet
den 39-jährigen aus purer lust am töten
mit dem ziel berühmt zu werden hat sie
geschafft traurig aber wahr und jetzt
wurde sie verurteilt aber zu wie vier
jahren jörg völkerling sascha baumann
und stefan xander wissen ist und haben
hintergründe zu dieser tat sie wollte
deutschlands berühmteste mörderin werden
sarah m eine zum tatzeitpunkt 18-jährige
schülerin aus franken am letzten tag des
mordprozesses gegen die sogenannte sex
date killerin brach sie endlich ihr
schweigen es ist richtig was im
haftbefehl steht sagte sie nach der
verlesung des dokuments dass ihr
mordlust und eine tiefe verehrung für
amerikanische serienmörder attestierte
das urteil zwölf jahre jugendstrafe die
schülerinnen aus bayern wurde des mordes
schuldig gesprochen
kaltblütig hat sie den 39 jährigen sei
in eine falle gelockt mit einem messer
auf ihn eingestochen und ihn verbluten
lassen für sarahs gleichaltrige freunde
ein schock ich konnte nicht drin sitzen
und einer guten freundin in die augen
schauen gegen ende hin habe ich sie dann
gefragt ob sie das wirklich getan hat
und ob das ein grund hat
woraufhin sie es in dem brief
geschildert hat sei jetzt familie lebt
im irak wir nehmen mit seinen besten
freunden kontakt auf lassen und
schildern was das opfer für ein mensch
war wir werden nie in erinnerung halten
dass er im krankenhaus lag und ist er
durch geräte beatmet wurde sondern als
dieser möchte uns immer alles getan hat
und der der sie hat einfach als einfach
er wie
gericht und staatsanwaltschaft sind
entsetzt ob der kaltblütigkeit von sara
n die erleichterung ist groß dass das
gericht dem antrag der
staatsanwaltschaft auf 12 jahre
gefängnis und angedrohte anschließender
sicherheitsverwahrung gefolgt ist denn
die täterin hat offenbar die anlagen
jederzeit wieder zu morden wir haben vor
dem sachverständigen gehört dass die
angeklagte krank ist und eine ausprägung
dieser krankheit ist eine innere leere
als ausfluss ist dessen dass ich
versuche mir einen kick zu verschaffen
und ich denke dass das die motivation
für diese tat war achtung fahndung
reporter jörg völkerling verfolgt den
fall von anfang an lässt sich von einem
experten eine einschätzung des urteils
geben das macht den fall so besonders
wenn man jetzt einfach die zahl der
frauen in sicherungsverwahrung
betrachtet wenn man ihr mut mordmotiv
betrachtet und ihre ihr alter sozusagen
die besonderheit stellt ihr da zum einen
überhaupt das nicht frau mit der
sicherungsverwahrung konfrontiert wird
weil wir in deutschland nur zwei frauen
haben und sie ist eine wäre dann die
dritte die zweite besonderheit ist dass
sie die erste wäre als heranwachsende
die anderen beiden frauen die momentanen
sicherungsverwahrung sind sind deutlich
älter und dann haben wir auch noch
dieses mordmerkmal mit dieser ruhm kette
sozusagen die sie ja da an der jva
auslöst und was sie genießt das auch
noch mal eine absolute besonderheit
es ist samstag der erste mai 2021 vor
drei tagen hatte sarah m bei
verschiedenen sex chat plattformen ein
profil eröffnet profilnamen domina jerry
insgesamt 241 männer haben seitdem auf
ihre profile reagiert bist du des
teufels braut schreibt benutzer emre an
diesem tag um 225 an domina cherry
höchstpersönlich antwortet diese wenig
später bringt sie sei
etwa eine stunde vor der tat schickt
sarah ihrer besten freundin franzi
mehrere sprachnachrichten sie sagt darin
ich gehe jetzt raus meinen ersten killen
wünscht mir glück während sie dann an
dieser bushaltestelle auf ihr opfer
zählt ewartet befragt sie google und
reddot wo gute orte sind um jemanden
ausbluten zu lassen und was passiert
wenn man jemand in den nacken sticht in
der hoffnung auf schnellen sex holte
sajed er sarah m an der bushaltestelle
unterleinleiter friedhof stoppt um 20
uhr 30 seinen wagen an einem kreuz auf
dem radweg neben der b 470 kaum sind die
beiden stehen geblieben schlägt die
täterin zu sofort rammt die 18-jährige
ihr quad camping messe zwölf zentimeter
tief ins herz sagte kann ihr noch das
messer entreißen stoppt auf der
bundesstraße ein auto doch 19 tage
später stirbt er im krankenhaus die
kielerin wird blutverschmiert im nahen
ebermannstadt gefasst nur 37 minuten
nach der tat wurde sarah m hier am
bahnhof in ebermannstadt festgenommen
dem polizeihundeführer sagte sie sie sei
ne scheiß mörderin und grinste nur als
sie abgeführt wurde
sarah m war schon seit frühester jugend
verhaltensauffällig auf youtube finden
wir ein bekenntnis zur selbstverletzung
sie hatte sich immer wieder geritzt ich
habe auch depressionen
selbsthass als diese ganzen dinge halt
ok auf jeden fall möchte ich euch sagen
warum ich das tue und warum ihr ist
nicht tun sollte falls ihr euch jetzt
fragt ja warum sagst du dir schon jetzt
nicht tun aber dann selber
es mich so was wie ein
ausweg aus diesem ganzen stress ist so
ist kann damit wirklich nicht auch schon
das ist wirklich eine suche schon mit
zwölf machte sarah die erste
bekanntschaft mit den behörden immer
wieder griff sie die polizei auf weil
sie die schule schwänzte fünf mal musste
sie sogar in die kinder- und
jugendpsychiatrie eingewiesen werden sie
wurde 2009 10 mit ecstasy erwischt und
mit auf die handgemalten hakenkreuzen
auch ihr freundeskreis war wohl mehr als
zwielichtig ihr freund dessen trennung
wenige tage vor der tat wohl der
auslöser letztlich war war als
polizeilicher intensivtäter bekannt
was bedeutet denn dieses urteil zwölf
jahre und vorbehaltene
sicherungsverwahrung für diese
angeklagte um dieses damoklesschwert der
sicherungsverwahrung abzuwenden muss sie
im rahmen der therapie an sich arbeiten
sie muss alle therapeutischen angebote
behandlungsangebote wahrnehmen sie muss
die therapeutin davon überzeugen über
jahre hinweg dass die vom gericht
ursprünglich gesehene gefahr beseitigt
worden ist und das ganze wird dann auch
noch durch gutachten zum gewissen
zeitpunkt überprüft um danach
festzustellen ist die tatsächlich
beseitigt worden die gefahren nicht und
nur dann hat sie worten chance nicht in
die sicherungsverwahrung hinein zu
laufen denn die gefahr die von sarah ihm
ausgeht war groß außer mit israel hat
sie für die tage nach ihrem ersten mord
mit noch drei weiteren männern feste
dates ausgemacht möglicherweise ihre
nächsten opfer auf dem weg zum ruhm als
massenmörder rinn
da kann man wirklich nur sagen zum glück
wurde sie gefasst und dazu bei uns im
studio ist jetzt professor christian
matz auf unser achtung fahndung experte
schön dass sie bei uns sind was für ein
fall oder wir beide haben hier wirklich
gebannt auf den fernseher geschaut ich
habe gänsehaut haben sie sogar schon mal
erlebt also in der klarheit und dieser
hätte die hier gezeigt worden dass er
nicht es ist ein ungewöhnlicher fall die
objektiven tatumstände die sind klar wir
haben einen tötungsdelikt mit mord
merkmalen was mich an diesem fall
besonders interessiert ist das was
hinter dem motiv steht das motiv schauen
würden wir das zu kurz gefasst was hat
dazu geführt dass ihr dieses motiv
entwickelt hat wäre die interessante
frage und letztlich was hat sich auf dem
weg dort ereignet bis zu diesem punkt
gekommen ist das müsste man untersuchen
und damit schließt sich eigentlich auch
noch die frage an ob man diese tat hätte
verhindern können wenn man achtsam
aufmerksamer gewesen wäre das soll kein
schuldvorwurf in eine richtung sein aber
es wäre vielleicht bei vielen
frühwarnzeichen möglich gewesen diese
entwicklung noch zu brechen und die
zeichnung ist ja relativ früh
aufgetreten sein ich meine jetzt sehr
gerade erst 18 jahre alt also das geht
natürlich auch in richtung der eltern
dann aber wir haben wird das gehabt im
zwölften lebensjahr haben mehrfach
aufgegriffen worden dass und auch
kontakte immer intensiv ist jeder szene
hatte also das sind alles schon aspekte
die zwar nicht dafür sprechen dass ich
später ermordet in dieser form aber auf
jeden fall für eine entwicklung die eine
gefährdung darstellt und möglicherweise
schief gehen könnte ganz abgesehen von
ihrem alter ist sie eine frau auch
ungewöhnlich dass sie sich auf einen
39-jährigen als opfer sucht morden
frauen anders als männer
ja da sind wir fast in einer art
überkommenen rollenklischee drin frauen
gehen andere straftaten und anders als
männer das ist richtig und frauen töten
auch anders als männer aus anderen
anlässen in anderen altersgruppen bei
den männern haben wir insbesondere die
jungen männer zwischen 18 und 25 die
oftmals im öffentlichen kontext etwas
eine straftat begehen wo es am
tötungsdelikt dann kommt bei den frauen
haben wir die situation dass im sozialen
nahbereich im sozialen kontext häufig
affekttaten passieren also
beispielsweise im rahmen der häuslichen
gewalt nach einem langen martyrium der
griff in den messerblock das ist etwas
was ich selber in einer dienstlichen
tätigkeit oft erlebt habe das dann aus
der verzweiflung heraus einen
tötungsdelikt entstanden ist das ist
eher frauen typisch und frauen sind auch
in allen altersklassen stärker vertreten
da gibt es nicht so diese fokussierung
auf die jugendlichen jungen frauen
insgesamt aber das ist ja dann auch ein
typischer fall auch in diese richtung
sarah wollte ja gerne eine
nachahmungstat begehen ihr großer held
ist dieser serienkiller aus den usa beim
skat gesehen dafür hat sie sich dann
aber nicht besonders clever wenn ich das
so sagen darf angestellt oder aber ich
habe so meine zweifel ist natürlich eine
diagnose aus der ferne aber ich habe so
meine zweifel was dieses serienkiller
werden und und berühmt werden angeht es
gibt natürlich immer nachahmertaten das
gibt es immer menschen die diese mobile
faszination interessant also diese
anzieht und frauen die mörderin in haft
schreiben liebesbriefe schreiben
ähnliches bei ihr kann den fall mit der
manson family und menschen
beispielsweise der viele nachahmer nach
sich gezogen hat ob sie wirklich das als
sanierung nur darstellt und daran selber
nicht glaubt oder ob sie daran glaubt
man vielleicht auf irgendeiner art und
weise etwas unerklärliches erklärbar
machen möchte da können wir nur mutmaßen
das können wir nicht tatsächlich nicht
beantworten diese frage vielleicht
später dann in der zeit wo sie behandelt
wird wird es darauf antworten geben
vielen dank